since avengers endgame has hit theaters
and the Disney Fox deal has come to a
completion giving Marvel and Disney all
of the rights to the characters that Fox
used to own many people are beginning to
wonder when are we going to start to see
the x-men and the Fantastic Four in the
MCU how's it going everybody it's Warren
and this has been long awaited for a
very very long time
the Fox characters returning home to
Disney and Marvel but now it has finally
happened and Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige is now in charge of running
all of the new characters that Disney
and Marvel got from Fox and today we
have news directly from Kevin Feige
himself that says Marvel has already
begun working on ideas for the Fantastic
Four and the x-men to enter the MCU he
revealed this in a recent interview with
Fandango so let's talk about everything
that he said and break down what it
could mean for the future of the MCU
also be sure to subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my Marvel Legends item
giveaway and stick around to the end to
find out more so in a recent interview
with Fandango Kevin Feige revealed a lot
about the x-men the Fantastic Four in
the future of the MCU he told Fandango
in the interview we were waiting for
Avengers in game to drop and for
spider-man far from home to be released
and now very shortly we'll be peeling
back the curtain and talking about the
future now this is just the first part
of what he says in this interview but I
want to note that he said if they attend
San Diego comic-con which we now know
they are he said
well there'll be a lot to talk about if
we're there I'll tell you that so it
seems like there's going to be a lot to
reveal at San Diego comic-con this year
including their plans for the future of
the MCU so Fandango goes on to bring up
the fact that Disney and Marvel now
owned the x-men the Fantastic Four
Deadpool and plenty of more characters
and when Fandango asked Kevin Feige what
the current process looks like for
introducing these new characters this is
what Kevin Feige had to say it's still
early days but it's been a fun exercise
it's one by the way that we've been
doing for years every development
meeting starts with cool ideas and fun
ideas and our wheels are always turning
in terms of what if to use a Marvel
publishing term what if we did this what
if we did that what if we had access to
such and such characters that's how
spider-man homecoming came together in
the first place and it
fun to now be in this position with the
Fox characters too because if we come up
with a great what if we can actually do
it and although Kevin Feige did stay
quiet about any specific characters that
they were going to introduce he did say
it's great to finally have what most
companies that hold a lot of
intellectual property have and it's
access to all those characters we were
one of the few companies that has a lot
of characters but didn't have access to
a whole bunch of them and now that we do
it's wonderful they're back in the
sandbox in the toy chest and now as
ideas come up and as opportunities come
up we can utilize them which feels
really nice so the official
brainstorming meetings have begun for
ideas of ways to introduce these new
characters into current MCU movies and
Fandango did go on to ask them if they
have any specific ways they think
they're going to introduce these new
characters such as introduce them into
group films like they did Black Panther
and then spider-man and then have them
do their own solo films and Kevin Feige
replied yeah maybe you know oftentimes
it just comes down to a specific
character in a specific story and a
specific way to introduce them so
sometimes like with spider-man and Black
Panther that made sense then other times
with characters like Iron Man Captain
Marvel Thor Doctor Strange ant-man it's
fun to introduce them in their own
movies first so it just depends on the
story we're trying to tell so Kevin
Feige and his team at Marvel are now
actively trying to figure out ways to
introduce the x-men the Fantastic Four
and all the new characters into the MCU
and based off of what he said in this
interview they've been brainstorming
about this for some time now there have
been reports recently that there is a
Fantastic Four movie being planned for
the release of 2022 could this possibly
be something that is going to be
revealed at San Diego Comic Con in Hall
H this year it will all be made clear at
San Diego Comic Con but it sounds like
Kevin Feige has been actively thinking
of ways to introduce these characters
for some time now so luckily for us San
Diego comic-con is less than a month
away now so we are less than a month
away from finding out more about the
future of the MCU be sure to let me know
how excited you are about this news in
the comics and be sure to subscribe to
my channel unlike the video so you can
enter my Marvel Legends series item
giveaway 3 winners will be picked at
four
and 50,000 subscribers and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof